>> Mike: FINALLY, TONIGHT, A
MESSAGE FROM BRET AND THEIR
FAMILY THINKING YOU STICKING
WITH US THROUGH ALL THESE YEARS
AND, OF COURSE, WISHING YOU ALL
A VERY NICE CHRISTMAS.
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR FROM A
FAMILY TO YOURS.
WE BEEN DOING THIS FOR TEN
YEARS.
SOME OF THE VIDEO IS PRETTY
FUNNY.
>> WE HAVE A LOT OF THINGS TO BE
THANKFUL FOR.
MERRY CHRISTMAS AND HAPPY
NEW YEAR'S.
>> WE ARE EXCITED FOR THE
HOLIDAYS, VERY EXCITED FOR
CHRISTMAS, WE ARE GOING TO GET
THROUGH IT HOW?
FAIR, BALANCED, AND UNAFRAID.
ALTOGETHER, FAIR, BALANCED,
UNAFRAID.
>> >> THAT WAS PERFECT.
>> THAT WAS A GOOD ONE.
THE FAMILY HAS CHANGED OVER THE
YEARS A BIT.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> HELLO, MERRY CHRISTMAS.
>> WE DIDN'T EVEN PLAN IT.
AMY?
>> WISHING YOU A VERY
MERRY CHRISTMAS FROM OUR FAMILY
TO YOURS AND A BEST 2019.
>> WISHING YOU AND HOLLY, JOLLY
CHRISTMAS AND HAPPY NEW YEAR.
>> WISHING YOU A VERY
MERRY CHRISTMAS AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR.
ONE YEAR OLDER AND ONE YEAR
WISER.
>> THERE YOU GO.
WHY IS THERE.
>> WE WANT TO DO IT FAIR,
BALANCED, AND UNAFRAID.
>> ♪♪ LAST CHRISTMAS, I GAVE YOU
MY HEART ♪
♪ VERY NEXT DAY MAMA YOU GAVE IT
AWAY ♪
♪ THIS YEAR ♪
♪ TO SAVE ME FROM TEARS ♪